and now it's time for bumming reviews
with Chester a bum
tonight's review Twilight new actually
that's a great rating good
you're serious yes this isn't Twilight
for you yeah all right you're absolutely
serious about you see the opening
credits all right do it again
tonight's review red button obviously
time I thought I knew I knew just go
with it you've ever seen in my life
Heyman may wait dependably spoilers do
you see girl named Red Riding Hood
Angele she's called something else but
you won't call her that and it's
season's over this boy who is like ain't
worth because it is Edward itself
obviously this is deal watching we fuck
dammit God's sake so obviously Twilight
sorry don't mind you guys get together
to take out the big bad wolf but it
turns out they kill the smalls like
ill-tempered well three but then Gary
Oldman comes in as the professional
werewolf hunter I am Gary Oldman I took
this world because it allows me to do it
to the accent did you read the script I
don't have to silly accent I'm on board
weird yeah so all the people are like we
don't need you we already kill the big
bad wolf and Coleman is like that's not
a werewolf I should know wait because I
was a vampire this is a let date winning
I told you shut up sorry million movies
like who could the big bad wolf be and
the movies like maybe it's the
grandmother till obviously it's not the
grandmother and I'll be like maybe it's
the boyfriend
so obviously it's not the boyfriend he's
like it could be anybody except the what
person we haven't said it could be yet
oh boo how'd you guess but in truth
everybody good can understand the
werewolf and he's like come with me so I
can take you far away but what do we do
you impose on the mountains like the
cover of a romance novel you'll stare
curiously at nothing and you're wearing
a club that's ten sizes too large and
you'll probably get caught on everything
when will you take me to Jacob No
thank you're watching this isn't lost to
everything who turns down his offer
because he's a frickin walls and
everybody think that she's always
because she didn't understand the wall
which is kind of true and you know the
boys she falls in love with have hair
gel years before it was invented me
something supernatural about that so to
lure the wolf out they chained her to a
chair and what this day a wolf mask on
her and everybody's like what is she
wearing the love mask is symbolic that
there is a beast and none of us even in
those be tough enough creatures and
it'll look cool and really cool in the
tree so comes above the gear behind the
church because the wolf can't enter on
church grounds did you like the movie
Sleepy Hollow only this one's not
intentionally funny I think
but the wolf bites Gary Oldman and
that's they have to came before you died
tell me what your accent was so she goes
to grandmother's house to try and save
her we know this and the boyfriend
arrives oh you said still loved you but
would you make sure the grandmother's
house it turns out there wasn't the
boyfriend it was her father
search your feelings you know it to be
true you should totally be aware of it's
like the coolest thing ever
bro you are invincible except for silver
churches sharp object the oh and the
fact that you can't go where other
people can go and everybody's trying to
kill you be aware well sucks but then
the boyfriend comes in and tells haha
hurry after getting bitten by him Hulu
so Red Riding Hood is like you risk your
life to save me even though I stabbed
you went down and you fought this whole
movie of course for that is what boys
doing tween girl porn so the boy is like
well I'm gonna run off and do my
werewolf thing but when the time is
right I will totally come back for you
oh yes I had a feeling you say that and
usually for me what yeah tween girl or
yes of course I will because that's what
every male thinks about only their
female counterpart and nothing else so
the boy is about to go up and live with
his werewolf emits but subtle even
to each other
oh that's a good point and here's some
collages of us making out because we
forgot to put it in earlier oh so
sometime later the wolf returns and red
just looks at him giving a seductive
gentle smile and the more that the
story's realities okay I mean they just
talk to the credits before anything else
happened what do you think they're doing
she's taking off his sheep's clothing
he's riding her hood she's blowing his
house down better to eat her with she's
taking up the Grandma's house keeps
checking under her hood holy smokes I
can make a book of these this is Jerry
boom saying to just catch me without
shaving for a week
you